hi Matt here I wanted to invite you to
check out our latest newsletter at
faster
smarter.io this newsletter covers
meetings how to run them better and be
better in meetings also at faster
smarter.io you can subscribe to the
newsletter see old editions find quick
tip videos along with our new English
language learning material finally
there's information about my new book
think faster talk smarter so check out
faster smarter.io today
the best communicators spend the most
time honing their communication they
work on storytelling understanding Their
audience making their content relevant
today we'll explore what's involved in
becoming a great communicator
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
[Music]
today I'm looking forward to speaking
with Carmine Gallo Carmine is the
founder and CEO of Gallo Communications
Carmine is a communication coach Harvard
Graduate School of Design lecturer and
the author of several books including
talk like Ted a presentation secrets of
Steve Jobs and his latest the Bezos
blueprint welcome Carmine I'm super
excited to chat with you and thanks for
being here Matt thank you thanks for
inviting me congratulations on the
success of your podcast I have been an
eager fan of this podcast because I've
loved so many of your interviews it's
very hard to stand out and it seems as
though you've been standing out by
helping others stand out well thank you
I appreciate that and I'm excited to
hear what we have to talk about today so
let's get started I know you spend a lot
of time helping leaders communicate more
effectively one of the things you talk
about is leaders are often translators
and I'd love for you to share with our
listeners what that means for you
because I wholly agree I think that's
exactly right help us understand how a
leader is a translator and what are some
things people can do to be better
translators in order for
anyone to take action on your ideas in
order for you to persuade persuasion
simply means combining words and ideas
to move people to action requires that
the listener understands clearly the
desired action
you're often speaking depending on your
field in a very different language even
if you're speaking to someone who's
speaking the same language that's not
the point you're using words and
complexity and jargon and shortcuts
abbreviations and acronyms that your
listener doesn't understand simply
because they're not in the same field
let me give you an example I think this
is the best way of describing what a
translator is I'm going to give you an
example that I've been thinking about
since I've been booked for your podcast
because it just happened recently I
spoke to a prominent Global scientist
her name is Annie kreitzer she plays a
crucial role in a recent headline
grabbing experiment in what's called
Fusion which is replicating the sun's
power for renewable energy a very
prominent scientist in stem and an
advocate for women in science so I
caught up with her and I asked her
please explain in plain English to a
non-scientist what is it that you
achieved because they made the again
this headline grabbing experiment what
she said is here's exactly her words
Carmine we're bringing the same process
that powers the Sun to the Earth
to harness the energy in a controlled
setting it's important because it's the
Holy Grail of the Clean Energy Future
anyone can understand that and
understand that she was using metaphors
like it's the Holy Grail harnessing the
power of the sun bringing it to Earth
simple understandable
I went back to Annie and I said Annie do
me a favor
how would you explain it to a peer how
would you explain this experiment to a
peer without missing a beat because it's
so easy for her to do it she said oh
that's easy we were able to achieve
ignition a rapid increase in deutritium
temperature associated with alpha
particle self-heating by increasing the
hot spot plasma energy density I had to
read that from a paper because there's
no way I could remember that
I was blown away mad I was like oh my
goodness it's a completely different
language on the Fly she could translate
this incredibly complex science
experiment and this milestone in science
she can translate it depending on her
audience and I asked her how were you
able to do this she said I did learn it
in school which is why we need podcasts
like this you don't learn this stuff in
school but she said communication is the
number one skill leaders need to align
teams around a bold mission
Matt if you cannot explain the science
to get buy-in from investors
stakeholders peers agencies Regulators
government if you cannot speak the same
language to different stakeholders and
adapt the language for those different
stakeholders you'll never get anything
done
thank you so much for sharing that
example Carmine that is a classic
Crystal Clear example of the power of
translation she knew her audience and
was able to adjust she used a tool like
an analogy to help all of us as leaders
in our roles we need to think about how
we can make our content accessible so
that people understand us so thank you
for sharing that I'd like to turn our
attention to some of your many books in
your book talk like Ted which is a great
helpful read your subtitle specifies
that you identify the nine secrets of
the world's top Minds would you mind
sharing with us one or two of those
secrets and how can we use those to help
our communication
talk like Ted was a book that I wrote
based on conversations with famous Ted
speakers so it's not necessarily a book
on how to get on a Ted stage how to fill
out the form and become a dead speaker
it's what can we learn from some of the
world's great speakers who have taken a
Ted stage in addition to Leading
organizations or their teams the one
thing in particular became storytelling
which is something that I know you've
covered in your podcast I know that it's
something that you teach at Stanford
storytelling is fundamental to not only
the way we communicate as humans but to
give in a TED talk or any powerful
presentation so one of the Ted
Commandments as they're really called
Ted Commandments these are the
guidelines for anyone who wants to speak
on a Ted stage is to not necessarily
start with a story although most people
do but it's to tell stories personal
stories because stories inform they
illuminate educate I think one of the
best examples of Storytelling is Brian
Stevenson Brian is a famous human rights
attorney who gave a very famous Ted
speech I talked to him after his Ted
Talk 70 percent of his Ted Talk were
just personal stories anecdotes from the
people he's met the people he's helped
or other folks that he has met and how
they created his personality and fueled
his passion for human rights and what he
does and so I asked him why do you tell
so many stories in your presentations
and remember this is a guy who wins
cases before the U.S Supreme Court so he
knows how to persuade and he said
Carmine you have to tell stories to
break down barriers between people
because it's through personal stories
that we connect with one another as
humans a lot of of professionals maybe
people listening to this podcast get
confused I think when we talk about
storytelling they say well I'm not a
novelist I'm not a screenwriter how does
storytelling apply to me well as a
species we're storytellers it's in our
DNA it's Universal across culture across
languages across countries you are a
Storyteller first what happens when we
create PowerPoints all of a sudden we we
lose our sense of story it's all about
bullet points and inserting text and
getting the right photo or image or
using the right font we forget the
narrative I believe any anyone who wants
to Aspire to a leadership position or
career advancement or actually wants to
get something done understand that
you're a Storyteller first PowerPoint
comes after PowerPoint or a presentation
complements the story but you have to
craft the narrative first that's the big
lesson I learned from the great Ted
speakers I'm smiling as you say that
because almost word for word I find
myself saying the same thing story first
story first and the notion that story is
built into being human absolutely
accurate and I really liked how you said
that story Bridges and connects us to
other people I encourage the people I
work with the students I teach to tell
me what's the story you're telling here
to get them to frame it as a story
rather than just a list of facts and a
list of ideas while many of your books
Carmine address influence and persuasion
a topic that our listeners are very
interested in your book five stars Dives
deeply into persuasion I have a specific
angle I'd like you to talk about when it
comes to persuasion how do you encourage
people to be more effective in their
persuasion in the midst of resistance
hesitation and concern about what it is
you're trying to persuade people on one
of the reasons why I focus on
storytelling is exactly what Brian
Stevenson told me you're most likely
going to be speaking to people who are
resistant to change so that's why you
have to use tools and vehicles that
connect one another and lower barriers
between people that's why storytelling I
think is a fundamental aspect of
persuasion storytelling check the other
is to think about the audience first
it's not about you it's about your
audience reverse engineer and I think
you do this too Matt you've taught this
reverse engineer the presentation
reverse engineer your pitch or your
argument what is the audience's pain
Point what keeps them up at night
whenever I speak to International
audiences or I travel around give
keynote speeches I bombard the
organizers and the people responsible
for those companies with a lot of
questions ahead of time I want to get
into the heads of the audience I need to
know what keeps them up at night and
then I reverse engineer the presentation
and my argument to help them
here in Silicon Valley where I live I
talk to a lot of Adventure capitalists
and people come in with their pitch and
they are enamored of their technology or
how cool it is or take a look at our
demo and they forget act one they forget
there's a three-act structure to good
storytelling and act one is the setup
explaining the status quo what is the
problem with the status quo people like
Steve Jobs were brilliant because they
could show you problems that you didn't
even know you had
until after his presentation then you
realize I think I do need that Apple
iPhone that's a brilliant persuasion but
I think it's audience first and I've
come to realize that very few people do
that they open their PowerPoint they
open a presentation and just start
filling in information that's important
to them or that's exciting to them why
should my audience care as you've said
so what
my background is in journalism and
journalism 101 first day of graduate
school
why should I care that is the the first
question you ask why should your
audience care about the topic that's the
headline
everything else feeds into the headline
and so I suggest we reverse engineer
presentations and pitches or any
business proposal of any type why should
your audience care what's their pain
Point how is your idea or solution going
to make their life better so everybody
lives happily ever after that's reverse
engineering the story
you summarize so nicely what many of our
podcast episodes have been about which
is really about structure and story and
about knowing your audience and what I
hear you saying the key to dealing with
resistance and concern and hesitation is
to make your argument your persuasion
relevant and Salient to the audience and
then work backwards from what their
concerns are and I love that concept of
reverse engineering and that's very
powerful and and I think we'll go a long
way to addressing the concerns that your
audience might have
you have two books about Steve Jobs one
exploring his approach to Innovation and
the other looking at his presenting your
newest book The Bezos blueprint is all
about Jeff Bezos
by your accounts both men were tenacious
they worked hard on their communication
and had specific approaches to it can
you highlight one or two communication
principles that each of these gentlemen
demonstrated and how we reading your
books and learning from you could
benefit from them it's a theme that runs
throughout my books whether it's Steve
Jobs or Ted Talks or a new one on Jeff
Bezos the theme that runs across my
books is is very clear to me now maybe
it wasn't clear when I first started is
that effective communicators in any
field
have practiced the skill communication
is above all a learned skill great
communicators are made not born Steve
Jobs was not born nor was he early in
his career
a charismatic stage presence like the
Steve Jobs that people recall from 2007
when he introduced the iPhone he became
one of the greatest business
storytellers of our time Jeff Bezos I
analyzed 24 years of his writing as
Amazon grew in complexity his writing
became simpler more concise easier to
understand and that's intentional that's
something that happens with both of
these entrepreneurs because they're
intentional about improving and working
on communication so the theme that I
have found and it's a valuable piece of
advice for everyone is that
communication is a learned skill public
speaking is a learned skill the minute
you think you know it all is the moment
you stop growing
I had a conversation with a famous
astronaut a Canadian astronaut named
Chris Hadfield who gave a very famous
Ted Talk he's called the singing
astronaut he's saying a version of a
David Bowie song while he was floating
weightless in space we were talking
specifically about his Ted Talk and he
said you know Carmine it was interesting
because I've been speaking as an
astronaut for 25 years I speak to Rotary
clubs and organizations and schools the
Ted organizers gave me some tips on how
to deliver a better presentation and I
learned a lot that's the point Matt good
communicators are learn it alls they're
constantly receptive to new ideas new
ways of communicating
if you think you're a good speaker a
good presenter and you don't need any
help I'll bet that you're not nearly as
effective as you think you are this
notion of continually developing in the
desire to improve is something I see in
all of the people I work with who have
really improved and who are and are
becoming good speakers this desire to
improve and being humble and giving
yourself a little bit of Grace to say
that there are areas for improvement is
really important and I appreciate you
highlighting that I feel many people
think that there's some end point when
it comes to developing communication
skills and I think what you've just
shared with us is what I see all the
time that it's a continual process
Carmen I've studied martial arts for a
long long time and I very much remember
when I received my first black belt my
instructor looked at me and said
congratulations now let's get started
and that to me was a very powerful
moment because it reminded me that
there's always more to learn and I think
you've highlighted that with regard to
communication thank you I love that what
a great anecdote yeah and it's been one
that's motivated me for a long time
before we end Carmine I'd like to ask
you the same three questions I ask
everyone who joins me are you up for
that absolutely excellent question
number one if you were to capture the
best communication advice you've ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be
storytellers Drive change and innovation
that one sentence encapsulated so many
of the things you talked about it's
about storytelling it's about being
persuasive and Innovative it's about
speaking in a way that makes your
content accessible wonderful wonderful
summary in those five to seven words
question number two and this one I'll be
very curious to hear from you who is a
communicator that you admire and why
I'll give you a modern contemporary
Communicator that everyone around the
world is going to know and that's the
billionaire Warren Buffett as we're
speaking I think is the third wealthiest
person on Earth Warren Buffett is an
intentional Communicator if you've read
his shareholder letters they're models
of Simplicity and he is an expert with
using metaphor to explain complex
Financial ideas so this idea of
investing in companies or stocks that
are surrounded by a moat that originated
from Warren Buffett and now Financial
analysts use it every day on business
news we like that company because it's
surrounded by a moat Warren Buffett is
very intuitive and understands that in
order to express ideas simply you have
to connect with people in language they
understand and that's often metaphors
and analogies that are familiar to them
so I would put Warren Buffett at the top
of my list as a contemporary
Communicator Warren Buffett has some
wonderful sayings is a great role model
and one of the things I admire most
about him is he is out front saying the
importance of communication he says one
of the best skills people can learn in
their education and practice is
communication so not only is he a good
role model he's a good advocate for what
you and I both do
question number three what are the first
three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe big
picture before details so again think
about your audience what's the big
picture what's in it for them why should
they care answer that in the first 60
seconds then they'll be hooked for the
rest of the movie get them to want to
watch the movie first in the first scene
so big picture first big picture then
details second ingredient is
storytelling reframe the way you see
yourself as a communicator you are not a
PowerPoint presenter you're a
Storyteller PowerPoint complements the
story and third and something very
important these days more important than
ever we are bombarded by complexity and
an overload of information
simplify simplify simplify
simplify by choosing simpler words
easier to understand explanations
less jargon shorter words to replace
bureaucratic language or convoluted
words I call Simple the new superpower
because I see how valuable it is so big
picture storytelling and simplicity if
you can Master those three ingredients
you'll be Head and Shoulders above the
vast majority of business professionals
you've given us a very clear rubric to
strive towards this notion of start with
the big picture make sure that it's
relevant audience specific and tells a
story and then finally make it simple
and accessible wonderful advice as has
everything you've said Carmine and with
such a pleasure not only to get to chat
with you but to watch how you model and
demonstrate the things that you talk
about thank you so much I appreciate
your specific actionable advice and
guidance and I wish you well with your
new book thank you so much Matt I
appreciate it and I really appreciate
the opportunity to speak to a receptive
audience people who get it and they
understand this skill and how important
it is so thanks again
[Applause]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn
foreign